anteriormente hablamos de la ley de los
gases ideales en la que suponemos que si
un gas presente en un contenedor se
comporta como un gas ideal y las
suposiciones clave son que no hay
fuerzas entre las moléculas del gas y
que el volumen de las moléculas del gas
es despreciable sobre todo en
comparación al del contenedor entonces
en ese caso podemos suponer que tenemos
algo que es prácticamente ideal y por lo
tanto podemos aplicar la ley del gas
ideal la presión por el volumen es igual
al número de moles por la constante de
los gases ideales por la temperatura
medida en que elvis pero en otros vídeos
también hablamos sobre esto y dijimos
que con los gases reales sobre todo
cuando se acercan al punto de
condensación no siempre podemos hacer
estas suposiciones entonces en este
vídeo vamos a explorar cómo podríamos
adaptar la ley del gas ideal que es una
mejor descripción de lo que sucede con
gases reales y en particular vamos a
explorar la ecuación de bander valls
llamada así por él mismo van der waals
quien descubrió las fuerzas de van der
waals que son fuerzas de atracción que
hacen que los gases reales desafían un
poco la suposición número uno y déjenme
ver si podemos modificar esta parte en
la que tenemos pib para describir mejor
a los gases reales entonces para
entender la ecuación de bander valls que
la veremos en un momento pensemos en
cómo podemos modificar p y después
pensemos en cómo modificar b entonces
empecemos con un contenedor y vamos a
poner algunas moléculas de gas
pongamos algunas moléculas de gas por
aquí ahora recuerden que la presión es
igual a la fuerza por unidad de área y
aquí la presión proviene de las
colisiones entre las moléculas del gas
que están chocando contra las paredes
del contenedor cada vez que hacen eso
en un poco de fuerza en esa área y es
por eso que entre más temperatura
tengamos las moléculas se moverán más
rápidamente y por lo tanto tendremos
colisiones más frecuentes es decir que
entre más moléculas tengamos existirán
más choques y entonces la temperatura
aumentará especialmente si mantenemos el
volumen constante ahora esto es
suponiendo que tenemos un gas ideal pero
vamos a pensar en cómo cambiarían las
cosas si tuviéramos un gas real en el
que si ocurren digamos fuerzas de
atracción entre las moléculas como las
fuerzas de van der waals entonces si
tenemos fuerzas de atracción entre estas
moléculas gaseosas podemos suponer que
las moléculas no se sienten atraídas por
las paredes del contenedor aunque no
siempre es el caso a veces se sienten
más atraídas a las paredes del
contenedor pero supongamos que no se
sienten atraídas a las paredes del
contenedor y vamos a suponer que el asma
se encuentran distribuidas en todo este
volumen y las moléculas que se
encuentran en el centro se sentirán
atraídas en todas direcciones así que en
realidad no tienen una fuerza neta
significativa pero las moléculas que se
encuentran cerca de las paredes del
contenedor por ejemplo si tenemos una
molécula por aquí bueno eso es lo que
tendrán muchas de estas partículas se
sentirán atraídas hacia la izquierda
entonces esto tendrá una especie de
fuerza que las jalar hacia adentro y lo
mismo sucede aquí esta partícula tiene
una fuerza que va hacia adentro y lo
mismo por acá y entre más cerca nos
encontremos del centro la fuerza
disminuirá pero como pueden ver debido a
esta fuerza de atracción es más probable
que las moléculas se muevan un poco más
hacia el centro que hacia las paredes
del contenedor hablamos de eso en el
vídeo anterior y bueno es lógico que si
mantenemos todo
constante la presión real la presión
real será menor a la presión ideal
debido en este caso a esta fuerza de
atracción y van der waals dijo bueno yo
puedo medir esta diferencia entonces qué
pasa si decimos que la presión real ya
sabemos que es menor a la presión ideal
por las fuerzas de atracción pero qué
pasa si la presión real es igual a la
presión ideal menos lo que queremos es
encontrar una expresión que nos ayude a
contabilizar estas fuerzas de atracción
especialmente de cosas cercanas a los
enlaces así que para cada gas será
diferente dependiendo de cómo
interactúen las moléculas entonces vamos
a poner una constante ahí ok entonces
para cualquiera de estas moléculas la
fuerza neta de atracción hacia adentro
será proporcional al número de moléculas
que hay adentro del contenedor y
especialmente a su densidad en
tenemos el número de moles entre el
volumen y eso aplica para cada una de
estas moléculas pero obviamente tenemos
muchas moléculas y el número de
moléculas también está relacionado con
la densidad así que necesitamos
multiplicar nuevamente por la densidad
entonces esto lo podemos ver como bueno
estamos tomando esto en consideración
para una molécula pero nosotros tenemos
un montón de moléculas y todas tendrán
un poco de esa fuerza de atracción en
diferentes grados y tenemos este factor
de proporcionalidad que nos ayuda a
tomar en consideración el tipo de gas
con el que estamos trabajando entonces
tenemos esta noción de que la presión
del gas real es igual a la presión del
gas y de al menos a por n / b al
cuadrado o incluso podemos manipular
esto algebraica mente si sumamos todo
esto en ambos lados de la ecuación
la presión real más a por n / b al
cuadrado y eso es igual a la presión
ideal ahora lo interesante de esto es
que van der waals dijo bueno si
suponemos que esta es la presión ideal y
este es el volumen ideal tal vez pueda
reemplazar p subíndice y es decir la
presión ideal por todo este término y
eso fue lo que hizo entonces hagamos eso
vamos a reconstruir la ecuación de van
der waals miren en lugar de esto él
escribió la presión real más
tal vez les parezca un poco difícil de
entender pero espero que ahora tenga más
sentido para ustedes acuérdense que la
presión real es menor a la presión ideal
por eso es igual a la presión y de al
menos algo o también podríamos decir que
la presión ideal es igual a la presión
real más algo y ese más algo está
relacionado con la densidad de las moles
que tenemos aquí y claro obtendremos una
constante dada específicamente para ese
gas ahora yo siempre he visto valores
positivos aquí que implican fuerza de
atracción pero si tenemos una fuerza de
repulsión bueno eso no lo veremos aquí
yo sólo he visto valores positivos para
los gases conocidos hasta ahora por eso
hablamos de fuerzas de atracción y bueno
después agregaremos algo relacionado con
el volumen entonces tenemos el volumen
real y a esto le vamos a sumar o restar
algo más y eso será igual a n
rt ahora vamos a pensar en cómo podemos
ajustar el volumen real en relación al
volumen ideal entonces voy a dibujar un
contenedor rápidamente
ok en este contenedor voy a desafiar la
suposición 2 primero vamos a suponer que
el volumen que ocupan estas moléculas es
despreciable entonces en este caso si
mantenemos todo constante es decir si
queremos mantener la misma presión y
todo lo demás constante para que podamos
tener la misma presión el volumen real
deberá de ser mayor el volumen real de
subíndice r tiene que ser mayor al
volumen ideal y porque tiene que ser
mayor
bueno si el volumen no es mayor entonces
las moléculas chocarán aún más entre
ellas porque necesitan más espacio del
que creíamos al suponer que el volumen
era despreciable entonces si las
moléculas chocan y rebotan entre ellas
si mantenemos el volumen constante habrá
más presión pero si queremos mantener la
presión constante tenemos que
incrementar el volumen entonces el
volumen real
debe de ser mayor al volumen ideal y qué
tan mayor bueno el volumen real puede
ser igual al volumen ideal y solo
necesitamos hacer espacio para el
volumen de las moléculas que tenemos
presentes entonces debe ser igual al
volumen ideal más el espacio que
necesitan las moléculas presentes más
constante por el número de moléculas
medidas en moles y esta vez corresponde
al tamaño de las moléculas podemos verla
como una especie de factor de tamaño de
hecho podemos pensar en que este es un
factor de atracción y este es un factor
de tamaño y nuevamente podemos manipular
esto algebraica mente nos queda que el
volumen real menos el volumen de las
moléculas presentes es igual al volumen
ideal entonces vamos a sustituir eso
todo esto es el volumen ideal entonces
el volumen ideal es
al volumen real menos una constante por
el número de moléculas en moles y miren
esta es la ecuación de van der vaart y
quise que viéramos todo esto porque al
principio se ve muy intimidante pero eso
es hasta que nos damos cuenta de que la
primera parte es simplemente la presión
ideal y la segunda parte es el volumen
ideal y simplemente aplicamos algunos
ajustes entre lo real y lo ideal
basándonos en algunas fuerzas que
existen entre las partículas y claro
también tenemos que tomar en cuenta el
volumen que ocupan las moléculas
presentes entonces la ecuación de bander
valls no es perfecta pero es la que se
usa normalmente como una versión un poco
más real a comparación de la ley del gas
ideal y bueno aún podemos seguir
modificando esto podemos hacer modelos
computacionales y muchas otras cosas que
nos den más exactitud pero la ecuación
de bander bayless
es un buen comienzo